the diversity consulting firm white men
as full diversity partners which
specializes in helping white males
awaken together which frankly sounds a
little creepy like i wouldn't want to
awaken with a bunch of other white males
those aren't pillows
meanwhile the biden administration
continues to wokify
the nation's military-industrial complex
so
the truth is that the government has
been engaging
in woke in woke priorities with regard
to national defense
for quite a while now the the gao
the u.s government's accountability
office put out a report in 2017
in which they openly talk about the fact
that the department of defense
actually obligates billions of dollars
every single year
to buy products and services from types
of businesses
okay and a business this is according to
the gao a business generally must
self-identify as a minority-owned
business or a women-owned business
as applicable in the federal
government's contractor registry
so there's like a specific part of the
budget that is basically dedicated that
it has to
be given to a female or minority owned
business now i don't know about you
but when i think about the military
making missiles for example or making
military hardware for jets
i don't care at all who owns the
businesses that sell that product to the
department of defense i just want that
stuff to work and i want to pay the
lowest price for it because it's coming
at taxpayer expense but the u.s
government for a very long time has been
engaged
in this sort of affirmative action
program for female owned businesses
and and black owned businesses designed
to direct money
toward specific i mean by in violation
of civil rights law
they they've picked specifically
minority-owned businesses in order to
direct
dollars toward those businesses even if
it's a greater cost to taxpayers even if
it means that there's a delay in the
procurement process because you have to
actually demonstrate apparently
that you couldn't have gotten it from a
black owned or a minority or a minority
or female owned business in order to
actually procure certain military
parties what i'm hearing from people
inside the defense department
okay so that's been going on for quite a
while and joe biden was set to ramp that
into high gear
according to governmentexecutive.com
this is back in 2020
the incoming biden administration is
likely to increase contracting
opportunities for small and
minority-owned businesses
president biden-elect said that he wants
to use equity as a guide
andy how her partner in the law from
austin and byrd's government contracts
group
says i think we're going to see more
regulation generally promoting
competition
and furthering the socio-economic
policies of the new administration which
is different in many respects from the
current administration
apparently this there was speculation
early on that the biden
team is now effectuating that would
expand
the small business administration's
small business development program to
increase participation of small
disadvantaged firms require prime
contractors to increase
subcontracting opportunities for small
disadvantaged businesses
and protect small business from contract
from contact bundling
because that would prevent smaller firms
especially those owned by black and
brown people from effectively bidding on
procurement
contracts now contract bundling is
generally a good thing because that
means that you have like a defense
let's say lockheed martin they have a
subcontractor and now lockheed martin
wants that subcontractor to go out and
get a bunch of parts well now you're
going to have regulations inside the
biden administration to prevent them
from doing that instead they have to buy
every part separately and show that
every single part
could not have been obtained from a
black owned or female owned business
before they can just go over to walmart
and pick up the part
how that helps america's military
readiness is absolutely beyond me
it has nothing to do with america's
military resident military
readiness especially in a time of rising
conflict with states like china
but beyond that we have now decided that
it's very important
that america's defense contractors get
engaged with the new woke military
priorities
of the biden administration there's a
reason the biden administration is
putting out these bizarre ads
in which they're recruiting for the cia
by being like here is a
a cisgender but very tolerant
hispanic woman with generalized anxiety
disorder you too can work for the cio or
here is a military recruiting ad this
person had two lesbian moms like what in
the world
well again this is about walkifying the
american military and turning it from
what is a quote unquote de facto
right-wing institution into something
that is much more woke
well now this is being crammed down on
america's
contracting companies things like
lockheed martin for example
so christopher ruffo does excellent work
on this sort of stuff
he has a piece today in city journal
says last year lockheed martin
corporation the nation's largest defense
contractor
sent white male executives to a
three-day diversity training program
aimed at deconstructing their white male
culture and encouraging them to atone
for their white male privilege
the program hosted on zoom for a cohort
of 13 lockheed employees
was led by the diversity consulting firm
white men as
full diversity partners which
specializes in helping white males
awaken together which frankly sounds a
little creepy like i wouldn't want to
awaken
with a bunch of other white males it's
weird like
i'm married and the lockheed employees
all senior leaders in the company
included erin huckabee director of
global supply chain operations retired
air force lieutenant colonel david starr
director of the hercules c-130 military
transport program retired air force
lieutenant general bruce litchfield
vice president of sustainment operations
and glenn woods vice president of
production for the air force's 1.7
trillion f-35 fighter jet program at the
beginning of the program the diversity
trainers led a free association exercise
asking the lockheed employees to list
connotations for the terms
white men the trainers wrote down old
racist
privileged anti-women angry aryan nation
kkk
founding fathers guns guilty and can't
jump
according to the participants these
perceptions have led to assumptions
about white men and diversity with many
employees believing
that white men don't care about
diversity have a classical perspective
on history and colonialism
and don't want to give away our power
the white man's full diversity partners
team jim morris mark haven's michael
welp
framed the purpose of the training
session as providing a benefit for white
men who embrace the diversity and
inclusion philosophy
in response to a prompt about what's in
it for white men the participants listed
benefits such as
i won't get replaced by someone who is a
better full diversity partner
i will improve i will improve the brand
image reputation
of white men and i will have a less
nagging sense of guilt that i
am the problem the firm's founders
welp and bill proudman have argued that
white males must work harder to
understand their white privilege
male privilege and heterosexual
privilege which affords them unearned
benefits this is what we're now
teaching people at lockheed martin now
why exactly is lockheed martin doing
this why are they bothering
the reason they're doing this is because
they want to be able to say to the biden
defense department
we have complied with all of your woke
dick tots we are on the team guys
keep directing those trillion dollar
checks over here please
this is not the first time that white
men as full diversity partners has been
involved in a controversial training
program
last year the company's white male
training program for employees at sanzia
national laboratories was performed
consultants such as white medical
diversity partners are peddling this
sort of stuff to bloated government
contractors
and the government contractors are going
right along with it because of course
they want the contract
so walkifying america's
military-industrial complex it is a move
it is a shocking move republicans right
now are warning of this
30 house republicans have now sent a
letter to defense secretary lloyd austin
warning him that creeping left-wing
extremism and politicization is
jeopardizing the us's military status
according to breitbart news and
christina wong reporting
the letter led by representative matt
rosendale republican montana said we
write to express our concern about the
growing trend of left-wing extremism and
politicization
of our armed forces the military's long
history of standing above politics has
made it one of the most respected
institutions in america
that legacy is now in jeopardy they
listed some examples of politicization
first was the diversity and inclusion
strategic plan for our special forces
the united states army also released a
recruitment video
describing marching in left-wing social
protests as defending freedom and
depicting two moms raising a child and
featured a lesbian at wedding
lieutenant colonel matt matthew lohmeir
commander of the 11th space warning
squadron at buckley air force
warned of radical ideology being pushed
on the military and stated quote the
diversity inclusion and equity industry
and the trainings we are receiving in
the military is rooted in critical race
theory
he was relieved of his command for this
hey
all of this is deeply deeply troubling
stuff and again remember joe biden
thinks the way that you compete with
china
is spending six trillion dollars in a
budget and also local finding the
american military-industrial complex
i think we are going to lose if this is
the way that you tackle
an authoritarian aggressive power like
china good luck
to you by the way just a quick side note
on the bizarre critical race theory
ideology and how stupid it is
there's this whole meme online called
people posting their l's
right people putting up tweets
describing things they've done that are
really just them describing how they got
their ass kicked online
okay so mark lamont hill posted a clip
of himself talking to chris ruffo
chris ruffo again doing excellent work
over at city journal exposing critical
race theory
and this really demonstrates wholesale
the perversity of critical race theory
thinking in which mark lamont hill
engages routinely marklemon hill is just
terrible
he was interviewing the he's
interviewing chris ruffo
and he says what do you like about being
white now this is a trap of a question
of course
because the real answer to this is i
don't understand what my race has to do
with anything
my race doesn't dictate my culture my
race does not dictate
my abilities my race does not dictate my
priorities
but marklemon hill wants to trap chris
ruffo because chris ruffo says
that i'm not proud of being white then
michael mount hill goes well
why not why not what are you guilty for
and if he says well here's the thing i'm
proud of being white about then he says
ah look at you you racist
right this is the trap this is the catch
22. chris ruffo refuses to fall for it
and michael manhill is proud of himself
for asking this dumb question
christopher what do you like about being
white what would you say
i don't know i again it's such an
amorphous term it's like a census term
or a
can can you can you indulge me indulge
me for once
just we're running out of time indulge
me for a minute i understand you see it
as as all these things but
you surely recognize that the world sees
you as white you know the world reads
you as white
and if you were to ask me some things i
like about being black i could talk
about cultural norms i could talk about
tradition i could talk about
the kind of commonalities i feel around
the diaspora if i were to ask you what
particularly if you're saying whiteness
is a thing that is being constructed as
negative and shouldn't be
name something positive that you like
about being white
okay and and chris ruffo rejects the
premise but michael mind help can't
understand why he should reject the
premise okay first of all it is
absolutely reductionist
to say what i like about being black is
all of these various
characteristics that really don't have
to do with race and really have more to
do with culture and history
right like you can be black and and
agree with none of the things that
markland hill just said there
but again this racial reductionism is
now being taught in america's military
settings i mean this is
this is madness i know what you're
thinking it's time to binge some more
ben shapiro videos well you are right
you should but first like and subscribe
perfect i'll see you in the next video